Aaron Sampson here to talk about what
we've learned from the battlefield
hardline beta battlefield hardline feels
like the best and I am saying this
intentionally that battlefield 4 can be
visceral has done a fantastic job of
wrestling the Frostbite engine into the
most workable state that it can in the
end though it's hard to shake the
feeling that it's the engine holding the
creativity of this team back the good
visceral beta Maps dustbowl bank job in
downtown are purpose-built for their
modes and that's awesome in battlefield
4 rush crates were haphazardly placed
around the map making for bland
sometimes flat-out unfair gameplay many
times conquest points seem to have no
rhyme or reason why am i defending this
ditch on Caspian border who cares
dustbowl and contrasts post both Hotwire
and conquest and really excels at both
visceral looked at what vehicles dust
storms or lack thereof an objective
placement leads to the best player flow
by flow I mean moving players into each
other at a regular and entertaining pace
and also I'll give credit where it's due
and removing jets which refocuses combat
on the ground where the game shines but
I do understand that this might have set
battlefield 2 fans visceral has also
massively improved the unlock tree with
a cash purchasing system players can use
any class to rack up cash in order to
buy gear or weapons for any other class
which removes huge barriers for people
who love class gear but can't get past
starting weapons both action sniper
rifles I'm looking at you weapons in
hardline are fewer but more unique and
the attachments aren't the same for all
weapons I opened up a battle pack and
actually got excited because the voucher
inside let me choose which weapons
upgrade on my own you can also purchase
ballot packs through in-game cash
instead of the extremely out of touch
with reality real world cash required in
battlefield 4
and lastly hit detection and feedback is
so much better than previous
battlefields
I finally know through a combination of
distinct hit markers for body critical
and vehicle hits where my bullets are
going when it get taken down I know
where the fatal shot landed and I can
adjust my play style overall shooting
just feels way better than cool
battlefield 4 now for the cons as I said
before frostbite is just working so hard
to make battlefield hardline work it can
be seen in the jitters when you run too
close to people in the vaulting problems
in skip car handling blow in wall
textures the list goes on go through a
trip miner get hit by a grenade launcher
in a car and watch frostbite use so much
brain power to figure out what just
happened when I play titanfall when I
play destiny
I rarely question the engine and I find
myself doing it all the time here battle
logs it's still the worst it's still
erases loadouts
and good luck finding out how to
actually use battle packs and boosters
and it requires constant updates
frostbite will literally not let players
kit out between rounds and for PC
players you still have to start around
in order to do your initial key
configurations I'd also be negligent and
not recognizing that to a lot of fans
this still feels like a mod people who
spent over a hundred dollars between
battlefield 4 and premium and felt
burned by it convincing them to spend
another $60 plus optional premium again
is gonna be an uphill battle
overall I'm reserving my judgement till
March 17th we need to see the full build
of the full game it is possible the beta
isn't utilizing the latest frostbite
code I really like battlefield hardline
I think it's a step in the right
direction of doing more games like 1943
smaller in scope and more focused on a
specific segment of the battlefield
community but I also can't shake the
feeling that frostbite needs to be
sacrificed to let Battlefield grow
[Music]